for the first time I understand real
fear
are you super fan of the actor formerly
known as Superman Henry Cavill well then
here are five titles to save the day
after three memorable Seasons as geralt
of Rivia on Netflix's hit show The
Witcher Henry cavill's run will sadly
come to an end with a two-part season
this summer and then Liam Hemsworth is
going to take over the role is that sir
now while you're waiting for the final
episodes to say your goodbyes to Henry
as geralt here are five more titles of
his that you have to check out starting
with big shocker season 3 part 1 of The
Witcher the Netflix fantasy show that's
based on a popular book series and video
game features caval as the main
character geralt of Rivia a mutated
Monster Hunter trying to find his place
in the world Cavill actively campaigned
for the role and was ultimately selected
from a pool of about 200 actors insane
critics were a little slow to come on
board during the ultimately fresh first
season but The Witcher has settled in
very nicely with a certified fresh
second season and a consensus that says
the show remains quote a whole lot of
fun with cattle bringing brawny Charisma
volume 1 of the third season contains
five episodes so plan accordingly and
the final three episodes are coming as
Volume 2 a month later and they're like
please don't hurt me and then wow
thanks just like a boatload of fangs all
up in your business next is our
certified Fresh Pick Mission Impossible
Fallout now this is the sixth
installment in the Mission Impossible
film series with Tom Cruise once again
reprising his role as the iconic Ethan
Hunt this time though Ethan and his team
joined forces with CIA assassin August
Walker played by Henry Cavill to try and
prevent an epic disaster as always
unfortunately August isn't who he
appears to be though at 97 certified
fresh on the Tomato Meter this is
actually the highest rated film in the
franchise all thanks to Henry sure why
not now critics say that this movie
quote lives up to the impossible part of
its name by setting it another High Mark
for insane set pieces in a franchise
that's just full of them Mission
Impossible Fallout can be found on
Paramount plus and it actually runs two
and a half hours but when you think
about how much time it took Tom Cruise
to do a bunch of his own stunts that
won't feel like very long
where's the needle didn't need it coming
in as our under the radar pick is the
man from Uncle this 2015 spy film was
directed and co-directed by Guy Ritchie
and it's based on the 1964 TV show of
the same name now in it Henry Cavill
plays a CIA agent who teams up with a
KGB operative to try and take down a
mysterious criminal organization that's
basically trying to acquire nuclear
weapons what's new Hugh Grant Alicia
vikander and Elizabeth Debicki round out
the cast for The Man from Uncle which is
fresh on the Tomato Meter now critics
say that with quote fizzy set pieces and
charismatic stars like Cavill and
Company the film has just enough style
to overcome its lack of substance you
can stream this one on Max in just under
two hours leaving you plenty of time to
go and watch all 105 episodes of the
original series from the 60s
things could get a little messy end of
the world that kind of thing how's that
for entertainment thanks to people like
you lovely folks our audience picked
this week is Zack Snyder's Justice
League released in 20 21 on the service
formerly known as HBO Max this is the
director's cut of the 2017 film Justice
League as the original director Zack
Snyder intended before he left the
production after a family tragedy now
the film is brought to fruition thanks
to an online petition created by fans
see kids making her voice heard really
does work it features Heroes like Henry
Cavill Superman Ben Affleck's Batman and
gal gadot's Wonder Woman as they come
together to stop the big Baddie
Steppenwolf now despite its four hour
run time fans love the Snyder cup which
has an audience score of 93 citing more
action and character development this
time around which was kind of the whole
point of the movement now critics dug it
too with a fresh 71 on the Tomato Meter
and consensus that says it lives up to
its title and fits Snyder's true Vision
like I said four hours is the time
commitment for this one but it's totally
worth it for the mere fact that an
online petition actually accomplished
something
now
and finally our throwback pick this week
is the Showtime series The Tudors
featuring Henry Cavill alongside star
Jonathan Rhys Meyers this historical
fiction series Chronicles the early
years of King Henry VII's 40-year reign
of England in the 1500s I mean that is a
serious throwback pick now as one of the
first major roles in his career Henry
actually played Charles Brandon a
military leader and Henry VIII's
brother-in-law so you know family drama
critics described Cavill and the rest of
the cast as gorgeous able and handsome
to go along with sturdy acting and the
show's stunning period detail all coming
together to equal three of four fresh
Seasons you can actually binge his show
in about 38 hours and if I'm being
honest It's Gonna Leave You wanting more
Henry Cavill tell me
Amazon Cleaves
I believe she is settled into her new
estate and shows every sign of being
grateful for your Majesty's charity and
generosity so my friends there you have
it five picks to fulfill all your Henry
[Music]
cow shows new love right here on Rotten
Tomatoes more like this my name is Naz
Perez and I'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you